but okay so this is what you're saying
you're saying like if you're gonna deal
with a girl
she's gotta like throw it back and
you're saying like [ __ ]
you have to throw it back you have to
otherwise dorm
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest frodo bambi music one rock
reading who's my baby that's kid named g
can't tell them why they'll make no
sense to speak
what
um today we are reacting to his new song
um am i the first one to watch that
you've showed this to like from youtube
yeah
okay so i'm the first one and before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell so
i was thinking
i could say what i think the lyrics mean
and you can tell me if i'm right or i'm
wrong okay okay hey joel always shooting
outside
[Music]
um
[Music]
right yeah so this is like like twerking
in a way
twerking yes shake shaking glasses like
twerking but in a real wretched way okay
what's the difference
um they got polite twerking and i got
rage it's working disrespecting sorry
can you can you show me is are there
examples of both in this yeah
so where would be places i could like
respectfully twerk
um
i'm trying to think
i think respect for target they'll be
like what you doing from your pants
and my parents
yeah oh no oh well i'm sorry excuse me
like my dad
wait let me let me watch it hold on
[Music]
i can't do any of that in front of my
dad
i don't
i don't see anything like i could do in
front of my parents
we drink the water
so do you guys do this like where is
this at oh
i think that was in texas
okay
oh so you guys just like run out of
house and like bring a bunch of people
there yeah like no
i only leave out of town whenever i'm
working so whenever i'm doing something
i like to knock a little stuff out at
the same time i was like hey it's
another video out he wanna come i get a
legend like a taxi
better hit it [ __ ] you won't forget it
i'm a [ __ ] good and leave my feelings
[Music]
throw it back
so i could do that as a family function
thanks but okay so this is what you're
saying you're saying like if you're
gonna deal with a girl she's gotta like
throw it back and you're saying like
[ __ ]
you have to throw it back you have to
otherwise door
is that is that right or wrong
i think he you sent me the dog he really
not better nothing
no no shimmies none no no
the bank's got to be thrown it's
throwing the banks
no no other options
go in the banks or you can back the
thorn
what's back the throne
you just throw it with the back
[Music]
i didn't really notice the difference
it kind of it kind of looked the same
once you have seen the amount of ads and
shaking and throwing back that i haven't
seen
it's like sick in nature
is that is that like um it's like seeing
a apple and orange
[Music]
i'm like a buddhiologist
a budiologist
i can tell what type of person you are
by you but
how
second nature no no yeah
your third eye
to the buddha so what type of person am
i
your sleepers
and you can tell based on them
[Music]
[Music]
she threw it back like she lived with
her granny
all cheeks that little day granted he's
sneaking out the house man they freaky
oh is it like because they want to get
out of the house
i don't know it's just like they'd be
the most rebellious yeah just think of
everybody who live with their
grandparents and not their fans
i don't know anyone you know grew up in
school and somebody say
they live later something yeah
that's that's why you can't open up your
third eye to the buddha
so
okay i get it so the freaky girls are
the ones that live with their
grandparents that's what that lyric
means
okay
that's kind of sad
yeah oh no
not saying i don't have one but they
they just ran out
i couldn't know how far the figure in
life
i like didn't make it better
[Music]
oh that was such a fun video
i liked it
yeah it did
hopefully it opened up your third eye it
was very catchy
easy i was telling her about uh the
third eye easy
i tell her uh she asked me about
throwing back and stuff like that and
i'll tell you you can judge a person
on a character by looking at their booty
yeah so if would you your third eye but
what if a girl is a bbl how would you
tell her character based on like her
beauty that's a lot of that's a lot of
uh deceitfulness inside her that's what
my most character will come out of it um
because
people have that in that one so this is
it's acceptable in some certain
so what about a flat butt what does that
mean
um a lot of those be depressing
the person oh they're depressed someone
more because because they don't they
don't be getting the love
and attention
but what if they're like if she's pretty
she probably still does see this i'm
saying yeah
there's it's like
so okay this is what i got is like a
theme from the song
and like you gotta tell me if i'm right
or wrong so first of all
the booty is like really important booty
is life
and the second thing is that
um
girls that live with their grandmas are
freakier
thanks
and the third thing is that if a girl
wants to deal with you she has to throw
it back or the door is over there she
had to throw it back go back to throw or
back the throat yeah did i what did i
miss
no i think your eyes don't know
now yeah i gotta do a good couple strip
clubs is it what y'all got a couple
strip clubs and you gotta judge the
textures
[Laughter]
would you take no butt but no bbl or big
butt with bbl
you know what you take the no butt no
i'm saying no but yeah like like a
little bit but not really oh okay it
apparently it depends on the firmness of
the smile but
so if you got the little wiggle
and but you still got the curve
i could deal with that
because the bbl you gotta think she got
that
for others to see mm-hmm so she don't
want to show it off you know so she's
not gonna want to just give it to that
one person
you know
[Music]
sensitive and jealous but that's how
serious the buddha yet it's that serious
you've written quite a few songs about
it right yeah like how many would you
say
out of all your songs what percent would
you say are about ass
well
four
forty percent
wow
that's so much
life okay guys um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel we're gonna we
can do like comment subscribe we can do
a couple right yeah videos okay
don't forget to like comment subscribe
and go watch
it
throw it back